حذرنا منه وحذرت منه روسيا ويحذر
منه العالم يوشك على الحدود.
بتصريح قاس متهما اللاجئين
الاوكرانيين باستغلال نظام
على تمديد هدنة اليمن. نعم.
الهدنة في اليمن تلفظ انفاسها ما
التشاور مع الحلفاء للرد بقوة
على صواريخ كوريا الشمالية عن اي
اصوات صافرات الانذار. وبعد ان
اطلق صاروخه ليتسبب بكمية رعب لم
مسلحة عنيفة قد تشكل مواجهة بين
الجيش الايراني والحرس الثوري
المؤامرة التي يعدونها ضدها.
فكيف ستنتهي هذه الاحداث ليظهر
هذه الضربات الرد العراقي جاء به
الكاظمي? حيث اجتمع رئيس الوزراء
الضجيج العراقي الى صخب
الاحتجاجات الايراني اشتباكات
شكرها لمشاركتها في مراسم اطلاق
في تركيا والذي سيستخدم في
التحالفات. التنقل من حلف الى
اخر ومن عدو الى اخر قد يؤدي الى
وكييف تغير من قواعدها بينما
زوجة الرئيس التركي اردوغان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي مجددا
ويقول الولايات المتحدة تعمل على
ولكنها تفعل عكس ذلك. فهل تظهر
واشنطن عكس ما تبطن حقا? ليخرج
يتساعدون في التصوير واعداد
المحتوى. انها فعلا قرية
جميع سكانها يوتيوبرز فسكانها
يعملون كصانعي محتوى يوتيوب حيث
بكين ليتعهد وزراء الدفاع
الامريكي والاسترالي والياباني
حيث لجأت الولايات المتحدة لحرب
التحالفات هنا يجتمع الجميع ضد
عندما تكون قوية وامرها بيدها
يحسب لها العدو الف حساب. وكما
هنا تهديد امريكي اوروبي جديد
لايران ولكن هذه المرة ليس بسبب
تهديداتها ودعت الى عقد اجتماع
طارئ لمجلس الامن الدولي للرد
على صواريخ كوريا الشمالية وكبح
جماح كيم ليخرج هنا وزير
ايها يجيب اوستن انه لا يرى غزوا
صينيا وشيكا لتايوان لكنه يعتقد
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
فقال ان اعداء طهران فشلوا في
مسعود برزاني للخروج من حالة
الانسداد ولمناقشة الغارات التي
الجزيرة. وبين هذا وذاك الدليفري
الامريكي لا يتوقف حيث تدرس
اعادة فتح قنوات الاتصال العسكري
مع الصين. فلما كل هذه المجاملات
وزارة الدفاع الامريكية دعم
القدرات الدفاعية لتايوان. وذلك
حازم وموحد. فهل حان الوقت للحرب
ان تندلع? قوة العيون الضيقة.
اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو تتطلب
موافقة جميع الاعضاء واي هجوم
ليس ذنبا. فقد اثاروا شهيته كثرت
مناوراتهم وكثر ضجيجهم لتتسرب
بالمئة من اراضيها ليلعب زيلنسكي
لعبة الاستفزاز مع بوتين موقعا
والاس ان بريطانيا ستشتري
سفينتين متخصصتين لحماية البنية
وقتل ما لا يقل عن اثنين وتسعين
في ايران في قمع التظاهرات
بانتصار عسكري ساحق على روسيا.
فما كل هذه الثقة المفرطة يا
ليعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي انضمام
مائتي الف جندي للجيش للقتال منذ
للناتو. ليخرج الامين العام حلف
الناتو ويقول اي موافقة لضم
الملف النووي ولكن بسبب قمع
صواريخ المجنون تتساقط. الذنب
في خطوط انابيب الغاز نورد ستريم
من روسيا الى اوروبا. ومن اقوى
متعمد على البنى التحتية للدول
الاعضاء في الناتو سيقابل برد
بوتين وقد ضاقت بها الارض بما
رحبت بعد ان اقتص بوتين عشرين
قوة تتحدثون. الاحداث والتطورات.
بعدما اثار موجة غضب عارمة
كوريا الشمالية. فما هو الرد يا
بينما قال البيت الابيض انه يتم
المساعدات زعيم المعارضة
الالمانية يعتذر. قرية في الهند
قصيرة وطويلة المدى على وضعها
العسكري للرد على استفزازات
الشعب العراقي من جوع وفقر او
حتى بظل سيادة يستند به ومن
الخارجية الامريكي. ويقول ان
بلاده مستعدة لاجراء تعديلات
يتلقاها العراق من تركيا وايران
فهل ستثمر هذه الاجتماعات لتغني
ابناء تشارلز ومن العمق السياسي
الى اعماق البحار. نعم الجيش
الجارية منذ بدايتها وذلك وفق
منظمة حقوق الانسان في ايران اما
والهدف وعمليات ضد المقاتلين
الاكراد. فبعد الضربات الايرانية
العراقي مصطفى الكاظمي برئيس
الحزب الديموقراطي الكردستاني
بان قوات كييف اخترقت دفاعاته في
منطقة خرسون وكييف تقول ان
فما هذا السلاح يا هذا؟ نعم. لقد
غردت ونشرت زوجة الرئيس
بالاستقلال عن بريطانيا. الامم
المتحدة تعلن عدم التوصل لاتفاق
تعشها اليابان الا في الحرب
عالمية لتطلق هنا بعدها اليابان
العجائب. مسيرات حاشدة في عاصمتي
ويلز واسكتلندا للمطالبة
تستضيف زوجة الرئيس الاوكراني يا
لهذه العلاقات الاسرية الحميمة.
الاسطول البحري الاوكراني فكيف
سيرد بوتين على ذلك? السيادة في
ما لا يحمد عقباه. هنا تركيا
التي تحاول الوساطة بين موسكو
تدفقها عبر الخطوط الروسية يا
لها من معارك طاحنة تدق الرؤوس.
اعلنت تركيا استهداف ثلاثة
وعشرين عضوا في حزب العمال
الدول الغربية التي تستعيد
بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
بصفقة اسلحة جديدة تشمل صواريخ
متطورة لكن بكين تحذر من هذه
خطر. اضرب واضرب حتى يعتاد خصمك
على الضرب ليفقد الاحساس بامتلاك
ان الصين تحاول فرض واقع جديد من
خلال انشطتها العسكرية حول
الرد من بكين. قائلة ان امريكا
تتحدث عن مبدأ الصين الواحدة
اعتبارات اخرى عن اي اعتبارات
تتحدث يا هذا ليأتي الرد من
فعن اي وساطة يتحدث الاتراك بعد
هذا. ليس ذلك فحسب فقد تسلمت
روسيا يمكن ان تؤدي لازمة عالمية
في حال فشلت. واذا ما نجحت
هما خياران لا ثالث لهما. الحرب
كر وفر. هنا الجيش الروسي يقر
الكردستاني بغارة جوية شمال
العراق. فكيف للعراقي ان يرد على
الى انفه رائحة البارود. فشاركهم
الاحتفال وجعلهم يرقصون على
الينا زوجة زالنسكي سلاحا من
تركيا قد يشكل خطرا على روسيا.
الاوكراني وعبر حسابها الرسمي في
تويتر والتي اعربت من خلاله عن
الاسلحة. نعم هنا الرئيس
الشيشاني يدرب ثلاثة من ابنائه
السيادة. نعم يا سادة دول الجوار
مستمرة في خرق الحدود العراقية
هنا رائحة الخوف في دول حلف
الناتو بدأت بالانتشار العالم
البريطاني في معركة بحرية حيث
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بن
موضح في العقيدة النووية الروسية
ولا يمكن ان تكون هناك اي
بهدف تعزيز تعاونهم العسكري
لمواجهة الطموحات للصين ليأتي
حالة من الهلع. الكل يسأل ما هي
هذه التجربة النووية التي
لغات العالم الصمت الى لعبة
التجاهل. كييب تتجاهل تحذيرات
هوليجرشي المقرب من بوتين. فما
الذي يجري يا سادة ليحذر هنا
الاسلحة النووية وزارة الدفاع
الروسية. وماذا بعد يا موسكو?
طبولها. ها هي بريطانيا تدق على
صدورها لتعطي اوكرانيا وعدا
مقدمتها رومانيا موقعة بيانا
مشتركا يدعم انضمام اوكرانيا
الصفقة. فهل ترد الصين بقسوة هذه
المرة? تركيا تدخل حرب
المطلوبين لمنازلهم هذا ما نقله
موقع سي ان ان الامريكي عن
ورقة لانضمام للحلف ليأتي الرد
من تسع دول من حلف الناتو وفي
تقديم تقييمات ونصائح مثل
استخدام نووي كما فعل كل شيء
التحتية تحت الماء مثل الكابلات
وخطوط الانابيب بعد حدوث تسريبات
يقولها المصريون. امش عدل يحتار
عدوك فيك. وهذا ما هي عليه الصين
سيجريها بوتين واين اختفى وحش
بوتين من القطب الشمالي. مع حرب
والرؤية ضبابية. نعم فبعض
الانتصارات لا تحقق الاهداف
بين ماسك وزينسكي تحت اعين
بوتين. وبينما تدق الحروب
اعلان التعبئة الجزئية. اذا فهي
حرب صامتة قد تقود لنتائج صادمة
الامريكية لتنفيذ خطة امريكية
اقتصادية مثيرة للجدل حول نفط
النووية. مهلا مهلا من هؤلاء
الصبية الذين يتعلمون على هذه
المراهقين لارسالهم للقتال في
اوكرانيا. فقديروف لم يكتفي
خوف حلف الناتو يؤكده الكرملين
والذي يقر بنصيحة قديروف
الايراني يرد. تدريبات امريكية
تشعل بحر اليابان ومجنون كوريا
بجيشه فقط. هنا لنا المتحدث باسم
ليقول انه يحق للحكام الاقليميين
اليمن تلفظ انفاسها الاخيرة.
رياح الموت تقترب. الوضع قاتم
لقطات لقطار شحن ضخم يحمل معدات
عسكرية متخصصة مرتبطة بقسم
كيف سترد موسكو؟ وزارة الدفاع
الروسية تعلن عن توجه مائتي الف
اوكرانيا مش حتقدر تغمض عينيك.
وفقا لصحيفة ديلي ميل فقد تم رصد
ما هذا الذي يجري الكرملين يقر
بنصيحة قديروف العسكرية واوروبا
قواتها احرزت اكبر تقدم لها في
جنوب البلاد منذ بدء الحرب مع
الاوروبية. اذا فشلت سيتجمدون
وتحل بهم لعنة المجاعة بوجه بشع.
سينخفض سعر الطاقة وسيكسر حاجز
المجاعة المتعطشة للدول
الصين والحرب قاب قوسين او ادنى.
تركيا تسلم اوكرانيا سلاحا قد
وقد وقعت سهوا وتم تسريبها الى
وسائل الاعلام الايطالية فقد
تكون في طريقها الى بحر كارا
لاختبار قنبلة بوسدون النووي.
اختفت بالبرود من قاعدتها
الرئيسية في القطب الشمالي وقد
ضخمة وقد تم ارسال مذكرة تحذير
من حلف شمال الاطلسي الى روسيا
الناتو من سلاح روسي لا يمكن
صده? بوتين ينشر غواصة نووية
شكرا لكم على النصيحة. اذا
فلتستعد اوروبا للايام القادمة.
خطيرة بعد قرار التعبئة والتحشيد
العسكري. موسكو تعيد الاف
الحرب النووية على شفا ان تجرف
العالم الى الهاوية فمن يوقفها?
حيادية. موسكو تنتقل في صراعها
مع الغرب الى زاوية ضيقة ومرحلة
كاملة. وهنا ننقل لكم الاحداث
بكل حيادية. الف خط تحت كلمة
الشمالية يشعل البحر اكثر. فعن
جنون نتحدث. دول المملكة المتحدة
سماء العراق وسوريا. وعشرات
القتلى في طهران والرئيس
يكون حاسما في الحرب. بينما ازيز
الطائرات التركية لا يتوقف في
تطالب بالانفصال لتتجرع بريطانيا
ما اذاقته للشعوب. والهدنة في
جندي. ولكن الى اين سيتوجهون يا
هذا؟ تستعين بهذه الدول لمواجهة
في خطر يا سادة؟ والناتو يضم
اوكرانيا ولكن بعد هذا الاجراء